let's talk about how to detoxify
thousands of toxic chemicals
out of your body but do in a way that's
very safe there are many
chemicals in our environment bisphenol
a pcbs heavy metals
certain toxic plastics and
bile solids have you ever heard of that
before bile salads sound pretty benign
right
but what you may not realize is bio
solids
are treated sewage
sludge it's a very interesting book that
i'm reading called
toxic sludge is good for you this book
is more about
how certain groups use pr
public relations to make something that
is normally
harmful to the environment and make it
actually
good for you so in this book they
describe
how they came up with this new term
biosolids
and actually redefined treated sewage
sludge
as a nutrient-rich organic
byproduct i'm not kidding i mean bile
salads contain over sixty thousand
toxic substances this is the stuff that
exits your toilet and it goes right into
a
sewage treatment plant where they're
processing this material
and actually selling it as an ingredient
in your pet food in animal feeds
and fertilizer there's at least eighty
thousand
probably hundreds of thousands of
different
poisons or toxins call it xenobiotics
that we're exposed to on a daily basis
now our bodies have a defense mechanism
for this it is a
series of detoxification pathways that
will turn these poisons
into harmless particles which is then
eliminated through our waste
and urine it's called bile
transformation where you have these
very powerful enzymes they're called
cytochrome p450 enzymes
that are meant to break down all these
poisons and keep us
healthy so what i want to talk about is
what you should be doing or eating
to keep these toxins from causing
disease here's a really interesting
book this is the international agency of
research on
cancer by the world health organization
and it's all about cruciferous
vegetables and a really big effect
is the ability of cruciferous vegetables
to induce
bile transformation so this is one thing
you should be consuming on a regular
basis
kale broccoli brussels sprouts cabbage
arugula bok choy
now bile salts your body makes bile you
can also take
bile this is very very important
anytime you do a detox you should always
start by taking bile salts for a few
days and then do your detox because
taking purified bile salts helps to
start the flow through the liver
because when you start to detoxify and
you start killing off
certain pathogens they release
endotoxins
that then shut down the bile ducts and
that's why you might feel toxic from
detoxifying so bile salts help you
eliminate xenobiotics
naturally a lot of the chemicals from
your liver should be coming out with the
help of bile
also the microbes in your gut help you
detoxify and they also have the ability
to make this enzyme to help you break
down these poisons
and one of the things i really recommend
is to combine
this with this so if you were to take a
pre-biotic
which is like a fiber let's say cabbage
and we ferment it
into sauerkraut cabbage is not just
cruciferous but it's a prebiotic and a
probiotic
so sauerkraut is a great food to help
you detoxify
and the cool thing about doing this with
food is it happens
slowly so you don't really feel it now
there's many other different
vegetables and herbs that will help you
detoxify
garlic is a big one rosemary
thyme and clove all have this enzyme
another thing to realize is a lot of
these chemicals create
a lot of free radical damage in the body
and the foods that you eat have
antioxidants
but your body also makes antioxidants
it's called endogenous
antioxidants especially when you
fast when you're doing fasting you're
putting your body in the state of
autophagy which not only accelerates
repairing the damage in the body but
also the clearing out of
pathogens but fasting will help increase
your endogenous antioxidant networks
so you'll have a lot more antioxidants
not to mention your immune system is
stronger
and the body will resist the stress from
the free radical damage
if you're doing organic foods
okay certified organic foods it's not
going to have these in them
the chain whole foods also recently
made an agreement that they're not going
to include any of their products with
bile salads
i would also make sure when you buy pet
food that you read the ingredients and
make sure it does not have
these byproducts because if you're going
to look at these nutrient-rich
organic byproducts it sounds like it's
really really
healthy but it's not anyway thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
video
before you go if you have a question
about a product or
you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call but i put the
number down below
so you can call and get some help